ces monuments aux morts ça dit la mort
d'un million 400 mille soldats ce qui
représente un maure pour 28 habitants
à l'issue du conflit et donc ses
monuments là ils sont là pour rendre
hommage à ces soldats et justifier le
décès d'un million 400 mille hommes en
france donc la justification et les
patriotique
elle est républicaine donc ce sont des
lieux de mémoire mais aussi un lieu où
on fait passer un message civique et
républicains pour le consensus de la
nation et puis enfin il faut pas oublier
non plus que ces monuments aux morts
ils sont là pour la transmission d'une
mémoire car les anciens combattants dans
la france de l'immédiate après-guerre
donc vont au nom d'une volonté
pédagogique faire du devoir de mémoire
avant que le mot lui-même n'existe donc
à travers un monument aux morts
finalement il y a plusieurs objectifs
plus on monte dans le relief plus on est
dans des régions catholiques plus le
symbolisme religieux joue une part
importante alors le financement
contrairement à une idée reçue ce n'est
pas une volonté de l'état que de
constituer ces monuments aux morts
ils ont d'ailleurs très l'état très peu
subventionné ces monuments
c'est surtout une volonté populaire et
qui émane des municipalités alors
l'essentiel du financement ce sont des
souscriptions et on a des exemples où on
n'a pas hésité dans certaines communes à
vendre un peu plus de bois pour financer
les constructions en question dans le
haut doubs particulièrement
oui c'est un monument très emblématique
parce que c'est vraiment un monument
très républicain il est pas belliciste
même si le bas relief de jougne rappelle
une attaque guerrière mais globalement
c'est la république qui avec une torche
montre le chemin qu à la façon d'une
déesse ouvre le livre sur lequel figure
la lie
des morts pour la france et devant le
monument un enfant donc lhi la liste en
question un écolier donc c'est vraiment
un monument qui n'est pas belliciste
mais il n'est pas pacifiste pour autant
et il met en avant la troisième
république dans toute sa splendeur au
tour de l'école laïque gratuite et
obligatoire
on les regarde le 11 novembre et lors
des grandes journées patriotique mais de
manière plus symbolique il faut pas
oublier que la nation c'est une
construction politique et qu' elle se
construit à travers des symboles et les
monuments aux morts participe de ses
symboles et on peut dire que quelque
part les monuments aux morts de 14 18
fond nation